how would you fix twitter how did you
fix social media for your own
like
you're an optimist you're a positive
person there's a bit of a cynicism that
you have currently about this particular
little slice of humanity i tend to think
i'm not that cynical about it i'm not
that cynical about it i actually refuse
to be a cynic on principle yes uh i was
just re briefly expressing some personal
passion personal stuff
it was just some personal pathos but
like
like
just to vent a little bit just to i
don't have i don't have cancer i've
i love my family i have a good life i'm
that
that that is if that is my biggest
one of my biggest problems it's a good
life yeah i i you know that was a brief
although i do think there are a lot of
issues with twitter just in terms of
like the public mental health but
due to my proximity to the current
dramas
i honestly feel that i should not have
opinions about this because
i think
if
elon
ends up
getting twitter
that is a being the arbiter of
truth or public discussion that is a
responsibility
i do not i i
am not qualified to be responsible for
that and i do not want to
say something that might like dismantle
democracy
and so i just like actually i actually
think i should not have opinions about
this because i truly
am not
i don't want to have the wrong opinion
about this and i think i'm too close to
the actual situation yeah uh wherein i i
should not have i i have my thoughts on
my brain but i think
um
i am scared by my proximity to this
situation is this isn't that crazy that
a few words
that you could say
could
change world affairs and hurt people i
mean that's the nature of celebrity at a
certain point um that
you have to be
you have to a little bit a little bit
not so much that it destroys you or puts
too much constraints but you have to a
little bit think about
the impact of your words i mean we as
humans you talk to somebody at a bar you
have to think about the impact of your
words
like you can say positive things you can
think of negative things you can affect
the direction of one life but on social
media your words can affect the
direction of
many lives it's crazy it's a crazy world
to live in it's uh worthwhile to
consider that responsibility take it
seriously sometimes just like you did
uh choose kind of
silence
choose sort of respectful
like i do have a lot of thoughts on the
matter i'm just um
yeah
i just i don't if my thoughts are wrong
this is this is one one situation where
the stakes are high you you mentioned a
while back that you were in a cult that
centered around bureaucracy so you can't
really do anything because it involves a
lot of paperwork and i really love a
cult
that's just like kafka-esque
you
know
just like i mean it was like a joke but
i know but i love this idea the holy
rain empire yeah it was just like a
kafka-esque um
pro bureaucracy but i feel like that's
what human civilization is is that
because when you said that i was like oh
that is kind of what humanity is is this
bureaucracy i do yeah i have this
theory
i really think that um
we really
bureaucracy is is starting to kill us
and i think
like
we need to reorient laws and stuff like
i think we just need sunset classes on
everything like i think the rate of
change in culture is happening so fast
and the rate of changing technology and
everything is happening so fast it's
like you know when you see these
hearings
about like
like
social media and cambridge analytica and
everyone talking it's like even from
that point
so much technological change has
happened from like those hearings and
it's just like we're trying to make all
these laws now about ai and stuff i feel
like we should be updating things like
every five years and like one of the big
issues in our society right now is we're
just getting bogged down by laws and
it's um making it very hard to
change things and develop things like in
austin like i don't want to speak on
this um
too much but like one of my friends is
working on a housing bill in austin to
try to like prevent like a san francisco
situation from happening here because
obviously
we're getting a little mini san
francisco here like housing prices are
skyrocketing it's causing massive
gentrification um
this is gonna be this is really bad for
um
anyone who's not super rich like like
there's so much bureaucracy part of the
reason this is happening is because you
need all these permits to build it takes
like years to get permits to like build
anything it's so hard to build and so
there's very limited housing and there's
a massive influx of people and it's just
like you know this is a microcosm of
like problems that are happening all
over the world where it's just like
we're
dealing with laws that are like 10 20 30
40 100 200 years old and they are no
longer relevant and it's just slowing
everything down and
causing massive social pain
yeah but it's like it's also
makes me sad when i see politicians talk
about technology and when they don't
really get it and but most importantly
they lack curiosity and like that like
inspired excitement yeah about like how
stuff works and all that stuff they're
just like they see they have the very
cynical view of technology it's like
tech companies are just trying to do
evil in the world from their perspective
and
they have no curiosity about like how
recommender systems work or how
how ai systems work natural language
processing how robotics works how
computer vision works you know
uh they always take the the most cynical
possible interpretation of what
technology will be used and we should
definitely be concerned about that but
if you're constantly worried about that
and you're regulating based on that
you're just going to slow down all the
innovation i i do think a huge priority
right now is undoing um the
bad
energy
um surrounding the emergence of silicon
valley like i think that like a lot of
things were very irresponsible during
that time and um
you know
like even just this current whole thing
with twitter and everything it's like
like there's been a lot of negative
outcomes from
uh the sort of technocracy boom but uh
one of the things that's happening is
that like
it's
alienating people from
wanting to care about technology and i
actually think technology is
probably some of the better probably
the best
i think we can fix a lot of our problems
more easily with technology than with
um
you know fighting the powers that be as
i you know not to go back to the star
wars quote or the buckminster fuller
quote
you